when a reporter asked President Trump
yesterday if he would attack North Korea
the president said we'll see mr. Trump
tweeted yesterday that North Korea's
words and actions continue to be very
hostile and dangerous to the United
States defense secretary James Madison
to his own message after a national
security meeting at the White House we
are not looking to the total
annihilation of a country namely North
Korea but as I said we have many options
to do so
USA Today Washington bureau chief Susan
page is with us from Washington Susan
good morning good morning good so
defense secretary mattis talked about
multiple military options the president
tweeted about economic consequences what
do you make of that talk well I think it
was interesting that the comment in
front of the White House as you just saw
was from the defense secretary from the
chairman of the Joint Chiefs talking
about a military response it didn't come
from the Secretary of State and you do
have the sense that while what the
administration is saying on military
options is the same as what previous
administrations have said which is all
options are on the table you do have the
sense that military options are more a
prior prospect now than we've ever seen
Susan Congress is returning this week
with a lot to try to work around here
debt ceiling tax reform policy
potentially in North Korea there's also
this news now that that President Trump
is looking to potentially and the daca
program for undocumented the immigrants
and children what what what happens with
daca now is in is the president putting
the ball in Congress's courts well
that's what we understand he's going to
do he's going to rescind daca those are
the reports out of the White House on
some sort of timetable and that is going
to create a real political firestorm
because we know that while the
president's base supports the idea of
ending this program and it's something
he promised to do over and over again
during the campaign that Americans
two-thirds in some polls three-fourths
of Americans support the program do not
want these young people at the risk of
deportation so this is going to create
some big challenges for the Congress on
whether they can act they've debated
this before and been able and able to
act and also what it's going to mean for
Republicans the next year's midterm
elections we've got the example
of California Pete Wilson in the 1990s
took action seen as very deleterious to
illegal immigrants and the Republican
Party in California has been paying that
price ever since Susan Jeff mentioned
that we obviously have Congress back in
session next week and this idea of the
debt ceiling being tied to Harvey we
know that they've got to get to that
Harvey relief right away what do you
make of this you know I think in this
way this terrible tragedy of this of the
hurricane of Hurricane Harvey gives
Congress kind of a way to get a debt
ceiling lifted that's helpful to them
you know that's usually the subject of a
lot of a political debate Republicans
often reluctant to raise the debt
ceiling but everybody is in favor of
providing some relief to these these
hurricane victims and so in a way this
might be a little helpful legislatively
to get that done they also need to get
funding the government down there a
couple things that Congress must do in
the month of September could it also be
helpful that we finally see some
bipartisan work there in Congress you
know I think that's possible and I think
that would be something a big relief to
Americans I think a lot of us watch
these scenes out of Houston and we're
really was really they were heart
wrenching because of the devastation but
kind of heartwarming because you saw
people working together and you saw the
government the local government seeming
to do a pretty good job in getting
things under control there Susan you
have any sense that tax reform goes
anywhere this fall you know I think tax
reform is one of those high priorities
that keeps getting lower on the list now
it's below North Korea it's below
hurricane relief below raising the debt
ceiling if daca is rescinded it's gonna
be a below trying to do something about
these young people who came here
illegally and brought here illegally as
children
I think tax reform was always gonna be a
big lift I think it just gets harder and
harder to see how that gets done does
the president still believe that Mexico
is going to pay for that wall Susan
because that's going to be a discussion
that Congress is going to take on you
know the president continues to say that
but from his conversation that we heard
about that recording that transcript
that was released of his conversation
with the Mexican president it didn't
sound like even the president thinks
that's really a realistic possibility
all right Susan page as always thank you
very much hey thank you